[Music]
hey and welcome back to stylecraft i'm
cameron and we are talking about depth
and for this final lesson on depth
for this week i want to show you how to
create something like
this and in this example it's two and a
half d
it's using a two and a half d camera
it's using uh
layers of photos that are stacked back
in z space it's using a little bit of
typography
some extra textures over in here it's
also using texture
as an atmospheric element and it's also
using a
um
piece of footage called large beam dust
that we used
last week with atmosphere it's from the
same collection that you probably
downloaded downloaded last week as well
so
it's fairly simple project you can see
there's only a few layers going on here
but uh the end result is pretty cool so
i want to show you how to go about
creating
depth with two and a half d
in this example
so let's start by creating a new
composition
and we'll make this 1920 by 1080
120 frames and we'll call this
depth comp
and the first thing i did was i brought
in
some photographs i had
uh downloaded off the internet
that are creative common photographs
and they are
free to use and you don't have to credit
anyone so
the first thing i did was i brought in
an image like
so
and i just decided to create some type
of
simple uh
layout okay and there's different ways
you can create layouts i just
thought you know that i would do
something very uh straightforward and
basic
which
ended up being something along the lines
of this was a tall image and a shorter
image and maybe i'll add in
one additional image
up in here
that will make it
slightly bigger
something like so
actually i'm going to delete that one
i'm going to create so what i'm going to
do now is i'm going to pre-comp this
select both layers right click
pre-compose
or go to layer pre-compose and we'll
call this
uh
photo
comp
one
and then we'll make a
bring in
this image
and we'll s
we'll make this
we'll pre-compose this one as well and
we'll call this
photo
comp
2
and we'll make both of these layers 3d
and we'll add a new camera
and we'll make this a
one node camera 35mm actually let's
change it up a little bit let's go 50
millimeters a little bit longer lens
depth of field is on
and we'll go ahead and turn
photocomp
to off
and the trick to this is i started
playing around with um my rotation
settings so i immediately went to the y
rotated over hit c on my keyboard
brought it back into view here
and i think i did a little bit x
something like so
zoomed out a little bit i did it this
way so that my layers are always flat
right so i could easily duplicate this
layer
take
the one behind it and
drag it back on z if i'll go to two
views here and you'll see that change
this to custom
you can see i just dragged the second
one back in z
i'll take photocom 2
maybe i'll put photocomp 2
in the
middle and i'll scale it down
trial and error here trial and error so
back in this one i'll turn the camera
back on
[Music]
and i don't love how it's kind of
so far back so maybe it's just a slight
x rotation five degrees
bring it back
pull it back a little bit more
and this is all i do when i do two and a
half d
i just
start positioning layers back in space
and i usually have two viewports up and
i'm looking through my camera here and
then moving layers around here a lot of
times i like to work in
custom view one also i like to work from
the top view
so i can see like this
and to be totally honest with you a lot
of times i get very um
i like numbers to be exact a lot of
times so
maybe i'll make this 500 i'll make this
a thousand
so i know that they're 500 pixels back
for this guy and then another 500 pixels
back for this guy
um maybe i'll move this guy up
slightly
i like him to be offset so maybe i move
him up
to 250
something like so
i'll go back to one view
and i'm going to
play around just a little bit more with
this
trial and error
oh something like that
and then how i got the movement was i
actually just clicked on option clicked
on position and i did my wiggle
expression and i think i did 0.5 and 100
and that gave me
this very simple but interesting kind of
camera shake
move going on
yeah it's just enough to you know add
some interest to it maybe i'll change it
from point one to one point five to one
and then also i roughly want this to be
in focus so i'll go back to my two views
and i know that that layer is this guy
right here and i will
hit aa on the keyboard and
pull up my focus distance
and this is a long lens that's why my
camera is really far back
i'm gonna crank the aperture way up
something like so
and reposition this on the x so that abe
is a little bit more in focus
like so
yeah it works for me and then i'm going
to duplicate this guy
bring them forward
maybe
somewhere over in here
just to give a foreground element to
this that's we don't have to necessarily
know what this is it's just giving it
some added depth
and then i think i also used yeah i use
this
writing right here
and really quickly i'll just go make a
background layer
i'll call it background
bring it to the back i'm going to lock
that layer and i do this because now i
can take
this writing and i can actually set it
to something like
uh multiply
and
there it is
maybe though actually i would like to go
to channel invert and make that type
white and because of that i can go back
to screen now
yeah that's a little bit more
interesting
and so with this type i'm going to make
it 3d as well
and maybe positioning it somewhere
i kind of like it as a nice little
foreground element right here
so now i'm going to go back to my custom
view
i'm going to
position it down
just slightly and then i'm going to go
into my
levels effect under color correction
and what i want to do here is i want to
make these this gray value more black
it's like that so that it blends in more
with the background so
um all i did was just bring the blacks
i crunched them in maybe i'll bring the
gray values
up just slightly
something like so
okay so i also used a couple textures
here
one of them was this chalkboard
like so i made it 3d and i think i used
it in the foreground in my original
example but maybe i'll push it back
into the background for this example
not sure yet i'm also going to bring in
this texture right here
maybe i'll try the same thing here
make it 3d
yeah that's more that's interesting
scale it up
kind of move it over on the x-axis here
yeah that's cool
i'm going to
change the transparency
of all these photo comps to something
like 85 so they're just a little bit
transparent yeah that's cool
and then i'm gonna bring this guy back
into the foreground here
and then i said that i also used this um
dust footage and that's what this guy is
right here so i'm gonna make it 3d as
well
maybe scale it down
[Music]
slightly or maybe scale it up a little
bit here
and then we're going to set this to
let's try screen
or maybe we'll try
yeah and i'm not liking how this texture
is looking
either so i'm going to actually pull it
back
oh that's the type okay here we go
and i'm going to try and reposition this
chalkboard again to make it
work with our image here
that's looking a little bit better
this is what i love to do when i'm
playing around two and a half d i like
to reposition layers
and just play around with them
i also added some type here i think i
said history
i made that layer 3d
and you'll notice here that the
history layer is not
fully white it's like this greenish
white because what i did here is i
selected
a color from my palette
oh something maybe actually we'll go a
little bit more white here
maybe a nice light gray
looks like so
add a new adjustment layer
and for this we're going to use an
effect we haven't used yet i don't
believe it's under stylize it's called
s film effect
really helps to bring things together
i load a preset here and there's one i
found there's actually a few i found
that i really liked
but uh
subtle innuendo is the one i actually
went with which we'll click here
now the one thing i don't like
immediately is this image looks really
out of place with these images and i
think that's because these images are
black and white yeah
so the easy fix to this is effect color
correction black and white
we could go in you can see that this is
definitely more contrasty than this
we could adjust things
to make it less contrasty like the reds
the yellows it's actually now it's a
little bit too bright
i don't know something like
doesn't have to be perfect
but it already blends in better
and then maybe i'll bring history
forward just slightly
so it's offset
we can read it just a little differently
actually let's pull it right here
and we're going to move this
column
remove this guy up
like so
and actually let me show you a trick
here if i make these layers 3d here i
can actually
push
one of them further back or pull them
further in space
and go back into my comp
and
if i collapse transformations on this
comp which is right here
it's going to respect the 3d space of
that photo so you see how this box all
of a sudden became three-dimensional
without it's just a flat box but because
there's a 3d layer inside of this if i
collapse transformations it recognizes
that and puts this layer
where it's supposed to be in 3d space
now if i wanted to adjust this easily i
could go again go up here to new comp
viewer
jump back into this comp
i could play around with my settings
here
my position
do
that's actually a little bit more
interesting and then i'll just readjust
history
something like that
and close this one out
and let's make sure that we can see
this guy right here
yeah i can tell that's way too big
maybe we'll rotate it on the
y 180 degrees so that's over in here
yeah it looks interesting
preview this and see what it looks like
here's the preview it's looking pretty
good there's a lot of depth going on
here a lot of parallaxing
um i could use some
some of the scripty words maybe back in
here in the back out of focus history
feels too crystal clear
um so those are the two things i
immediately see i want to change up
so let me duplicate the writing
go back to my two views here
drag it back
and over
and you can see here the problem is it's
behind the chalk
board texture here so if i change the
chalkboard
oh to something like overlay let's see
what that does well it makes it really
dark back there but it's kind of
interesting
screen
so that's screen and that's
normal screen yeah so we lost some of
our imagery back there which we now got
back which i didn't even notice that
before so that's cool
so we'll go back into that texture
maybe bring it back in here
somewhere
we'll scale it down
it's much too large
i'm gonna rotate it
try negative 90.
i don't like let's try this
yeah i don't like now how uh
you can really see the edges
of it yeah there we go it's just messing
with the gray values
got rid of some of that
now it's really difficult to read
history so we need to reposition history
maybe it's
somewhere over here
yeah it's a little more out of focus now
which makes it look a little nicer
and just for the hell of it i want to
try and add a glow
glows always work pretty well with
comps like this
so maybe we'll add it before the film
effect
after
let's go back to after
[Music]
we'll turn up the threshold so not
everything is glowing
and maybe we'll widen it out a bit
and turn down the glow just a little bit
so this is before after before after
very subtle
bringing them just a little bit more
before after
i'm good with that and then
just add a little bit of chroma warp
we'll load this preset
and we'll make it subtle
just to give it a little bit of realism
which is why i use this
plug-in because it does add that little
bit of just imperfect nest to it and
makes it look a little bit more real
in fact that feels like it's just a
little bit too much so if i take it from
point nine seven to point
nine eight
very subtle
but i like it
okay let's preview this
so there's a short little preview of it
looks pretty awesome
um a couple things i want to change
really quickly
is i think i want to turn down the
amount of depth of blur depth of field
i'm sorry
uh it's 9 34 maybe let's try 450.
let's just shut it off for a second
so that's interesting but it's really
dirty which is
this texture i believe right here
yeah
so if we turn that texture off
and then turn depth of field back on
yeah it's a little more clean at this
point i think that texture was just
making it
yeah really dirty
uh for my taste
so maybe we could duplicate the
chalkboard actually
bring it forward in space
so it's kind of like a texture that sits
over the top of everything
and change it from screen to
maybe lighten
and turn it off
on off on
very subtle
texture um
i like it though multiply let's see what
this looks like
so we did multiply and we did a channel
invert
to make the black white and the white
black
darkens it up a bit
i think i actually prefer
screen without invert
i take that back i don't
okay and
let's try it without
with without width so i'll crank this
back up to let's go in the middle 650
maybe 700.
and i want to try just one more film
effect
see
how it looks with a slightly different
look and i have one in mind which is up
here somewhere
that one right there let's try and load
that up and we'll compare the two of
them
so this is the new one
and this is the old one
new old definitely like the old one
okay so one more thing i want to do here
is i want to
[Music]
bring
this guy
forward even more i want to see more
of this
dust
going on here so i'm going to duplicate
the layer
maybe bring it forward just a bit
over a bit
something like that
and i'm actually going to bring in one
more
piece of footage here
subtle dust it was in one of the packs
you downloaded for
atmosphere
and let's just put this in here drop it
in how about let's try
screen so with
without
actually let's replace this with a
swirly dust that's the other one that
came with it let's see what that one
looks like if it's a little bit more
yeah it's a little bit more dust
actually it's too much dust
right below that
cool
okay i want to add another adjustment
layer here
and i want to do something with the
flicker so let's go let's add a little
bit of flicker i think that'll be really
interesting wasn't in the original
example
but uh
sometimes flicker can be pretty
interesting to add
especially for stuff that's a little bit
older like this
yeah see that campfire's got a nice look
to it that's too much
out light might be kind of cool
so i'm going to say it's between
campfire and out light which
i do like campfire it's a little bit
slower
and we will turn down the amplitude
or the random frequency to maybe
five
and let's preview this
and there we go there's the flicker
added there's the two and a half d
there's the depth there's the camera
blur there's the atmospheric depth
overall it looks really awesome in my
opinion so i hope you guys enjoyed this
lesson hope you learned something new
leave a comment let me know what you
thought until next time i'm cameron and
this is motion science